schnell
[Musik]
der neue film
man kann schon für terrence malick eine
liebe zwischen zwei paaren ist in
einander verlieben ineinander spindeln
und am ende doch nicht richtiges zustand
ich weiß das ist das live muss ich den
ganzen michael fassbender produzenten
angeber geld sagt er und und nette
department kommen eben zusammen und
bilden ein wenig hart bei den
anlaufenden bank haben sex miteinander
ohne es einander zu inkludieren reden
miteinander
obwohl sie sich eigentlich ist das ganz
andere beschäftigen wollen das
interessante inhaltliche konsequenz weil
es eben sozusagen die super
sexualisierung seelische einsamkeit
unserer zeit irgendwie ein fact die
anderen beiden und für die würde ich
sagen lohnt sich der film mit ryan
gosling und rooney mara entwickeln im
laufe des films immer stärker eine form
von einheit einer naivität wie sie mit
diesen intellektuellen anspruch des
films umgehen also sie werden immer mehr
zu kindern in körpern von erwachsenen
könnte man sagen und zu einer ganz
anderen form von paar nämlich einer
liebevollen zutraulichen art der
verbindung die ihn nicht mit stolz und
eben auch nicht mit sex zu tun
wenn man einen presse für diese beiden
schauspieler hat dann ist der film auch
auf jeden fall sind erzähl mir
irgendeine liegt das sagen was du willst
die besetzung des films verspricht
natürlich großartig das ist es nicht
ganz ehrlicherweise gesagt dem ganzen
geschehen aneinander geschnitten die
nichts miteinander zu tun haben und die
schauspieler reden nicht wirklich
miteinander sondern die stimme kommt aus
dem oft wirklich man so sagt
und gleich ganz anders es ist ein
verspieltes mit einer physischer
ästhetik film der die ganze zeit fühlen
ich für mich sagen will
im kino im schlimmsten sinne des wortes
ich kann das alles aufgeben das wirklich
ganz böse streben von malick und 18
die rückkehr zum einfachen zur natur zur
stationsstrasse machen und das versucht
er in bilder um zusätzlich und scheitert
meiner meinung nach damit und bilder zu
einer erzählung zusammenzuführen sie
bleiben eben aneinander gereiht
[Musik]
stück